okay so
i'm going to talk about abstractions and
what they look like in rust compared to
other languages and what the performance
looks like
so just a little bit of background on
abstraction so that we
we're on the same kind of page
abstractions are really
kind of what we deal with as programmers
they're higher level concepts
and it's a way of us it's a way that we
go and
ignore essentially the irrelevant parts
of the problem and focus on the detail
that's important
abstractions are very helpful because
they allow us to clearly express what
we're doing and also reduce the
cognitive load
and errors that we get when we're coding
so
i mean there's numerous examples all
familiar with it but some of them are
for instance just using a higher level
language like java or c-sharp instead
of like c or assembly um other things
are using classes or interfaces or
traits
using iterators and functions instead of
imperative loops
there's tons of these now
considering they're so important in
programming languages it's quite
interesting because
abstractions are not always free so
today we're actually going to look at
iterators as an example of this so
let's look at some c sharp stuff here um
at a very high level
we could have some algorithm like starts
like you've got a bunch of numbers in
two vectors
and if the first number uh at least
if the number in the first vector is
larger than 2 then we want to multiply
you know the first vector and the second
vector together or the elements at least
and then add them to a sum so that's a
sort of expression in
you know pseudo code you can then write
that in c sharp
um as you know take vector a zip it with
vector b
pick out pairs where you know the first
one's larger than two
multiply them together and sum them so
this is a nice sort of high level
abstraction
and then in theory the low level is that
you'd get some assembly that looks like
this
in reality though that's not the
assembly you get
so we'll have a look at this in a second
so
here is what c sharp looks like
so if we go and take the
iterator approach here so now
va and vb are both vectors they've got
20 000 elements in them
if we take the iterator approach here
the nice one
then we land up with us taking 400 milli
400 sorry microseconds
if we go and do the direct loop where we
just
iterate through you know just with a for
loop
and just take indexes and you know do
the usual thing
that is nearly 10 times faster just
because of the way
that c sharp deals with iterators
then you can go lower so you can go
and do you can go and manually unroll
that loop
in c sharp and you can put unsafe around
it to get rid of bounce checks and all
that sort of thing
and you can make it another four times
faster than the direct loop
and then if you want to go completely
crazy you go and write this
avx code here which we're not going to
go into in detail for the c-sharp stuff
this is in github so you can check it
out later if you want
um but that takes this 47 milliseconds
and brings it down to
sorry micro seconds and brings it down
to two microseconds
and this is pretty much as fast as
you're going to get on well
my processor so if you plot the whole
thing on a graph
um it's pretty telling i mean the ovx
version is down here
the iterators sorry the iterated
versions up here
and you know the direct loops here so
for something like this yeah you
definitely want to use this
instead of this because this is actually
extremely expensive
so yeah that's c sharp let's look at
java next
uh java doesn't really get away with
this either um
the doesn't really have a zip function
in java so
i wrote my own one or i pulled in the
google
guava library um the google one comes
out at 900 microseconds
the sorry my phone's realized i'm saying
google
shut up phone um the hand coded one
265 microseconds and the direct loop is
pretty much as you'd expect in c
sharp uh and java both about
45 microseconds um so yeah just added
those to the plot there
and again you you're better off just
doing
you know straight up indices again
because
yeah it's just how it works i'm assuming
scala fares better but i haven't
actually tested it
because they do make more use of these
sort of iterators and stuff
but uh i'm still expecting them to be
relatively expensive so yeah somebody's
done that let me know
so yeah now that we've done that let's
look at rust so
the first thing i should note um i've
changed the axis here
zoomed it in this used to go up to 800
at the top here and it zoomed into about
50 here
so this is where the direct stuff is in
c sharp
and java and this
is where all the rest results are so
why is this we'll talk about that next
but
rest abstractions are often even faster
than a straight up loop
and the times we're looking at here are
three microseconds up to maybe six
microseconds
and i did a direct um avx2
implementation that came out at 1.9
so these are all very close um
and we'll look at the avx stuff and you
can decide later if you
would want to go down that path but
essentially the reason is that the
the compiler knows all the tricks so it
knows how to do branchless programming
it knows how to use avx instructions it
knows how to unroll loops inline
functions that sort of thing
so the net result of this is that you
can decide to do
something using an iterator
you can use either of these sort of
patterns or anything else you really
want to
do and they're pretty much going to give
you very fast results
so it allows you to kind of express the
way you
like to do things i personally kind of
like this way of doing
things it's very easy to understand
and you don't run into issues where
you're going to run off the end of the
array
or anything strange like that um
so yeah next um
we'll talk a little bit uh about what
um some d instructions look like and
actually
look at some of the support that we have
and rust for them
so as a quick refresher of what cmd is
single instruction multiple data it's
essentially
modern um modern processors have
very wide registers that you can use so
that you can actually do
operations on multiple uh data elements
at the same time
so if you've got you know you do one
instruction and you operate on like
four or eight items so
if we look at sse2 this is the older one
the registers you'll see in a debugger
are called xmm registers they're 128
bits wide
these are available on all intel and amd
processors
if you have a 64-bit one and you're
doing 64-bit code
it's pretty standard you're pretty safe
using this for everything
um and it allows you to get four 32-bit
install floats into a single register
then avx is the newer one by newer i
mean anything
post 2013 so it's still pretty old
um these are 256 bit wide registers
you've got avx and avx2 the avx standard
is mostly floating point and avx2 is
mostly integer stuff
and this allows you to get eight 32-bit
integers or floats into
into a register so once you've got that
register loaded
you could add it to another register you
could multiply it shift it
to an and operation there's there's like
probably thousands of instructions there
and it's really really fast because
you're typically issuing a single
instruction
and the process is going to operate on
eight data elements at the same time
so it's yeah it's pretty quick avx
uh just a couple of caveats it may not
be faster than all the
older intel cpus they
have some issues with talking they also
don't like doing unaligned loads and
things like that
but on more modern hardware that really
isn't a problem
and if you do feel like you want to use
avx instructions it's a little easier to
use than sse
because they're non-destructive they
don't overwrite
themselves the registers so but yeah
you'll see that when you get into it
you're kind of interested in that
so in rust this is kind of the
interesting stuff
it's a it's an area that's rapidly
evolving
you can just ignore the code on the
right for the time being and we'll talk
about
what's available unrest at the moment um
so there's currently stuff on stable
rust there's stuff on
unstable rust there's some future stuff
that's happening
and we'll talk about whether you should
use it so currently on
stable rust you don't actually need to
do
uh these sort of avx instructions
directly
most of the time because if you're happy
with
the three or four milli microseconds for
you know that loop and you don't want to
get down to two
um llvm will automatically vectorize
loops and use
these sort of instructions anyway
provided you tell it what processor
you're using
so if you target the correct processor
by changing your cargo
config and your project or rust flags
you set target cpu to native it'll use
whatever's on your machine
if you set target cpu to a specific one
like skylake
that does support avx2 it will also
generate those instructions
there's some good documentation in um
standard arch
um you know the documentation in
standard harch uh will tell you how to
detect processes and do those sort of
things
if you do want to get lower level
currently on stable the only way to
really do it is to use intrinsics
and only x86 64 intel is supported
and they are luckily the same intrinsics
as in c plus
so there's good documentation and stuff
this is very
unsafe and it is very low level and
you've got to go read the intel
intrinsics guide
and there's various other references as
well to understand what's going on
you've got some crates like some d's for
slightly higher level code if you want
it
um but yeah that's pretty much what
you've got and then you can produce
code that looks like this which yeah
it is faster but it's a lot less
maintainable
currently on unstable rust you've also
got intrinsics for arm
webassembly web assembly is going to
have intrinsics as well
and various other things so that's going
to be pretty cool
when they start stabilizing some of this
stuff you've also got inline assembly
for most platforms
including ones that don't have
intrinsics
and then you've got some cool crates
like faster and packed zmd for
higher level code and that stuff really
simplifies
this kind of thing but it's not
available unstable yet
because this is a very active area and
changes are expected
so they're not going to stabilize stuff
until they're really certain that they
have got the right approach so in order
to do that
they've formed a rust portable cmd
working group
and they're working on the kind of
standards that might go into a standard
cindy
kind of thing and that will allow for
you to have like a generic set of
instructions
and you know vectors that work across
different processes like arm and intel
and those sort of things because
there's a lot of stuff which is similar
but every instruction is
different and then you know the way
things are packed and aligned is
different so it's a hugely complex
problem
and it's going to take a little bit of
time for them to solve but
i think we're going to get there at
least at some point
so the question is yeah should you use
this stuff
um the answer is maybe
so if we looked at the we looked at the
uh
algorithm that we had before and we
compare it to this
thing that we've got here on the right
the the very simple iterator approach
was only about twice as slow as this
so the relative benefit of doing this
sort of stuff here
is a lot lower than the relative benefit
of doing this sort of stuff in a
language like c
sharp if you do it in c sharp it's
literally 20 times faster
if you don't rust it's only two times
faster so perhaps it isn't worth it
however if you have got something which
is extremely performance critical
and it's really going to make a big
difference to your life it's going to
make a massive difference to your
product or something
maybe it's worthwhile actually getting
into this um
and doing this sort of stuff a lot of
this says
you know it's unsafe because the
compiler can't verify
um you know what these instructions do
they could uh if you don't have the
correct processor like if you've got a
really old processor and you issue this
instruction
it will crash um likewise
this thing where we're loading stuff
from a pointer
into a register this is a load you
instruction so it's load unaligned
if you change this to a load um that
will crash
but it won't crash every time it'll only
crash when the pointer happens to not be
aligned
uh with a 256 bit alignment
so sometimes it will work and sometimes
it won't and when it doesn't you'll just
get a seg fault
so a lot of these instructions aren't
really
fundamentally unsafe but they do
things that rust would consider unsafe
so
there's casting and you've got to
understand what sort of variables you
have and
you've got to understand the kind of
conversions that are going to happen
internally
so these are all things that rust can't
verify so they all at the moment go into
a big
unsafe block one thing i'd like to
highlight here
um this is a very useful thing chunks
exact
it's really really useful so if you've
got two slices and you want to take
uh you know eight items at a time chunks
exact is really cool because it'll give
you eight items
and then you know you can let it do the
loop accounting there
and then we can just do stuff like load
those um
eight items into a vector and do the
operations we want there
so yeah that'll give you the eight
bits that are there and then you just
need to do something with the remainder
um so in that case we just call into
another function that adds up to last
three or whatever
so yeah that that's kind of like cindy
and rust um
rapidly evolving quite interesting if
you want to learn some x86 assembly
stuff it's not a bad place to go and
fiddle
um so yeah some conclusions briefly
because we don't have too much time
abstractions are very expensive in some
languages
so for all developers i think it's
really important to know how to identify
hot code files
because a lot of people get told that
these abstractions are expensive
and then they'll go back into their
favorite language and start replacing
every single iterator with the loop
and that's really the wrong approach
because you don't need to do that the
you've got to identify where the hot
code parts are so
if you're doing very little work inside
the loop and you're doing it lots and
lots of times
then the loop itself becomes important
if you're doing something
expensive inside the loop and you're
going through it 10 times
then it doesn't matter then just use the
iterators so
that's one thing i really want to stress
figure out and know how to identify
where the hot code parts are
so yeah use use classic loops for those
and use abstractions elsewhere know how
to do micro benchmarking and profiling
that's another really important thing
people don't necessarily understand
where the hot code pads are because they
don't understand how to use tools
to identify where they are you can only
do so much by inspection
then if it's a really hot loop you could
consider doing some more aggressive
optimization
so it could be some d or if you're in c
sharp or java you can actually use some
of the classic optimization techniques
like loop unrolling
the jet compiler is in a hell of a hurry
and it won't actually do those for you
as things improve the jet compiler is
starting to do slightly more stuff
but it's got nothing on like rust or c
plus plus it's just in too much of a
hurry
you've seen how long c plus plus and
rust and so on take to compile
there's a reason for that the compiler
is doing a lot of work
to make stuff fast so in rust here
the the equations are a little bit
different use the abstraction they're
fast
and sometimes it's even faster than
using a direct loop because the compiler
is able to see what
variables aren't being changed and what
are
mutable and those sort of things and
it's able to do some optimizations
which often results in the loop being
extremely fast
the other thing is target the right cpu
rust won't use those instructions unless
you tell it
it can so you know if you're building
your software for
um aws or something like that you can
just go and use avx because all their
xeons are modern
let the compiler do all of the hard work
and
uh yeah if you want to check your
assembly you can add dash dash emit asm
on your cargo config or your rust flags
check out godbolt.org i'm going to give
this a little bit of a plug
this is a tool which decompiles
c plus and shows you assembly
and you can go and check it out for
different um processors and so on but
the thing is they also support rust
so that's really cool so if you want to
go and just copy and paste some
code in there and see what it compiles
to an assembly
and go and tweak it a bit in there
absolutely an awesome tool for that
then for benchmarking rust criterion is
an excellent crate
that allows you to do some really cool
stuff so i'd recommend that as well
then this yeah this is a plug here on
why
people should learn some rust because
this is originally a presentation i
don't work
and yeah the reasons for that simply a
language that empowers everyone to build
reliable and efficient software
and i think the way it deals with
iterator abstractions
are a demonstration of that it's also
stack overflow's most loved language yay
hope it wins again this year um there's
a quite a lot of the learning curve
but it's really useful outside of rust
too functional devs will enjoy the type
system
there's really good really good tooling
and
there's a cool mascot and yeah if you
guys want to go and play around with the
code or have a look at what i've done
there's the github repo
so yeah thanks